all right so we have Austin here Austin
Reef founder of uh morning Brew uh I I I
I know how big you guys are I don't know
what the public numbers are so I'll let
you kind of say like how big is the
company now yeah 70 75 million of
Revenue this year uh double digit profit
uh margin 250 people or so
[Music]
and it's kind of crazy kind of a crazy
story you guys started this you guys
were at college right you're you're at
uh is it Michigan where you guys went to
school yeah so so we're at the
University of Michigan uh I applied to
Duke didn't get in though unfortunately
sorry and so I went to Michigan yeah I
went to a small private condolences uh
so I
no Michigan worked out well it was a
little cold a little bit colder than
Duke but I
I mean my goal was to go to the biggest
school I could get into other than you
know Ivy or Duke so I got to Michigan
had no idea what I wanted to do uh and
everyone went to finance of Michigan so
I was like oh I gotta I gotta follow the
herd I was a sheep following the herd
straight into the world of corporate
finance or Investment Banking uh and
then stumbled upon this guy Alex
Lieberman who was like I wouldn't even
call a newsletter it was a PDF attached
to an email he actually took a he made a
Word document he would PDF it and put it
to an email and that was the first
newsletter so he was all he was already
doing it was it called morning Brew no
it was called market corner it was way
more Market space way more Finance
oriented was he in college as well or
was he had he graduated yeah so he was
two years older than I was and that's a
big part of our success to be honest uh
if I was his age we probably would have
went out and raised Venture Capital so
you know 20 2015 you have BuzzFeed
raising money Vice raising money and the
only reason we didn't follow that path
was because I was in college and no
one's going to fund a sophomore in
college and so Alex went to work at
Morgan Stanley for 14 months I spent the
summer in Investment Banking and was
like holy [__] this is miserable get me
out of here and so I was like all right
well I got this morning Brew thing I
might as well do it for a couple years
and what's the worst thing that happens
I come back here and that was the that
was the start of going full time
what did your nice Jewish parents think
about you not becoming a banker and
instead working on a newsletter so my
parents were actually okay with it
except I told them after my junior year
I said I have one more year of college
what if I I just don't go back what if I
don't finish and the idea of them
spending a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars on three years of college and
not finishing my senior year drove them
nuts so the deal we made is if I
graduate and they were cool with me
doing morning Brew for a year or two
after and then fast forward you guys so
it was funny uh right when we were in
the process of selling you announced
that you had sold like
months or two months uh and it before us
and so you guys sold a portion of the
business I think the majority of the
business for at something like a 70
million dollar valuation in that
ballpark right yeah right around there I
think we were actually we were doing M A
at the same time we were even talking to
some similar Partners I I think we were
and the reason why like Sean and I
wanted to have you on because we want to
talk about newsletters which every all
three of us have a newsletter business
but you and I have an interesting
background we're like on paper we kind
of hated each other like the whole time
I hated you dude I hated you so I didn't
entirely hate you I just it was it was
like I uh it was like Just Sports a
posting sports teams where I was like I
have a lot of respect for this person I
don't know anything about their
character but I'm gonna make up the
story in my head to like motivate me and
the reason why I wanted to do that was
because we so I launched we technically
launched the hustle in April April 2016
were you before us or after us we were
25th teen when we launched the first
newsletter but it wasn't it was a very
small thing though so we were going like
back and forth it was like the skin was
like the thing and then it was you and I
morning Bruno and the hustle and you
guys were this like a New York kind of
buttoned up crew I was like a little bit
of a crazier person it was Tech San
Francisco but it was like everyone kept
comparing us and I remember like wanting
to like Crush you guys and then after we
built sold Alex called me and uh you and
I became buddies and I was like oh no I
actually love these guys and now at this
point you and I are great friends and I
have a ton of respect but uh yeah like I
wanted to crush you I didn't I didn't
really hate you what did you feel yeah
look I think it's always good for a
business to have an enemy I think in the
early days our enemy was the skim very
quickly though we were like you know
what they're not our enemy we realized I
think we both realized pretty quickly
that you can't raise 25 million dollars
for a newsletter and have a good exit
and so I think it was you and us and so
I turned you into that enemy and I was
so immature at the time right this was
my first thing out of college I knew
nothing so I was like here's this guy
he's so abrasive he's so aggressive like
what the [__] like I was so I I
wasn't principled I didn't have real
values at the time and so I just saw you
who are super valued right you have
strong principles very strong principles
which some people love tons of people
I'm sure don't like uh and I was like
this guy is just so abrasive and I've
learned to love that about you but the
time it just it rubbed me the wrong way
and I was like we're gonna make this guy
our enemy and we're gonna crush this guy
dude I used to get mad because
everything that I was bad at you were
good at and everything that I was good
at I thought you guys were bad at and
I'm like [__] they're just stealing all
my ideas from my ads and them Runner
they're stealing all my content ideas
and then I would see how you guys
operate and I'd be like no we gotta have
all these sales people just like the
like I remember I was at your office and
uh
I and you were talking about morning
brew and you were like I thought you
would just hate them and be like they
suck because uh I feel like that's how
we used to just talk about most people
at most startups was just like oh my God
they suck and especially one that's
doing what you're doing then it's like
oh I already want you to suck so I'm
gonna say that and instead you were like
God why is this email look better than
ours and you would just like show it to
the whole team and you're like look at
this why does this look so much better
than our email look at what they do at
the top like God they're so like they're
just like they're so much better at that
you know like the the formatting or the
cleanliness or like the brand that
they're doing at the I remember at the
top of the email and I was like wow he
just respects the actual like craft so
much that he can't even hate him fully
he's like ah they're doing good at these
three things
Sam I'll give you a story I think I've
ever told you which is you know there
was a time where I thought our copy was
much better than yours our editorial and
then there was a time where I thought
you guys passed us right and Alex in
particular was maniacal about this he
would print out morning Brew in the
hustle every single morning
by line we'd sit down line by line and
we'd be like that Line's better no our
Line's better no that and we go line by
line some of the early morning Brew
employees they really hated you because
when you wrote a story that we wrote and
when yours was better and Alex thought
yours was better people I mean people
were pissed they're like a Revolt in the
morning room office one morning because
people were like no ours is better and I
think ultimately it wasn't better or
worse right it was just catered towards
different people but I mean yeah we
printed out your newsletter every day
and read through it through it for I
don't know six months nine months like
we were just so focused like I've never
been as hyper focused as I was in 2018
on us writing the best newsletter
growing the best newsletter and selling
it like I woke up every day right Gross
cell right gross out like we wrote it in
the wall and at 11 A.M every single day
we had the Great Wall of opens and we
track our open rate and right down the
wall and we had that for probably two
years running every day what was our
open rate and your strategy was to our
our strategies were they diverged and
they were different so we were going to
launch we're gonna stay in this space
and verticalize and launch subscription
services and all this other stuff you
guys launched multiple different
newsletters which met from my eyes you
grew your Revenue quicker I personally
hate that business because I don't like
advertising that much but you grew your
Revenue way faster than us
um well I think you did like we if we
were one year behind you I think we were
tracking one year behind so the year we
sold I think we could have done 18 or 20
million in Revenue which is around you
were I think the same year so we're like
tracking perfectly which is really
interesting but you went this horizontal
route where you launched multiple
multiple newsletters
which route do you like looking back
look I mean it's tough to say we took
the round the wrong route uh but I also
think it's what we had to do right we
didn't have the choice you had because
our content was more General business
right you wrote with an edge with a tone
you were targeting uh entrepreneurs or
maybe like account Executives who want
to become entrepreneurs and so you had
way more opportunity to launch a Trends
or to launch a hustle con uh for us we
thought you know a general morning Brew
subscription wasn't going to work a
general morning Brew event wasn't going
to work the the tone wasn't specific
enough the the
Target customer wasn't specific enough
but we fell in love with this B2B
business which I know both of you gotten
a little bit of a Twitter [__] when you
when you spoke about the B2B world and
you know industry dive but we I fell in
love with that business and I'm like wow
if you can get in front of retail
professionals and HR professionals and
we have them in our newsletter and it
was the craziest business where we'd
launch a newsletter and it'd be break
even before we even hired the writers
because we pre-sell uh you know
Advertiser like let's call it like a B2B
SAS company into one of these
newsletters and so I don't think there's
better or worse I think your our
opportunity was easier to get to 100
million of Revenue yours was easier to
get to let's call it like a a billion
dollar uh company right because you
could have subscription multi-revenue
stream much easier it just was going to
take another you know eight to ten years
that's great I'm happy I'm learning that
now after I sold it
I'm happy I got to see it because I just
got to copy both your playbooks and do
that do it for the milk Road like all
three of us were able to win with the
same Playbook mine was the easiest path
of all because I could just text you
guys and be like hey uh thinking about
doing uh your thing but for crypto uh
what do you think it was like yeah I
think it's gonna work let's do it they
did the Playbook work perfectly Sean you
think it has so far right we basically
less than a year we built the number one
like the biggest daily crypto email
it's profitable it's you know seven
Figures it's I don't know like it worked
as well as one could expect bootstrapped
it you know in our spare time like
that's like as good as I could have
expected that to go
dude that's why these businesses are
awesome is people don't realize that's
why I always hate when people say if
you're going to start it over again what
would you do I'm like do the same thing
like it works it consistently works I
know uh Austin you're way more like
pessimistic you got you're like I'm
pretty paranoid you're way more paranoid
and I know you say like oh it can't work
again and I'm like no man I think I
forget awesome you have like a framework
around you have like a lot of opinions
around email newsletters give us that
and put it in the context of milk Road
like when I told you I was gonna do that
or you saw I was gonna do that
what'd you think and did that fit your
framework for what you thought might
work or was that a maybe an outlier what
what was it yeah so it perfectly fits
the framework so I'm pessimistic on
relaunching the next morning brew a
general business four million person
email uh but basically I split up
newsletters into three categories one
are the editorial newsletters right you
have your sub stackers your your packing
McCormick's full newsletter maybe 2000
words maybe 10 000 if you're some of
these writers uh that's like category
one right category two is what we did
aggregation right and Sam and I kind of
went more General General business went
for scale and then
uh after that you kind of have like the
let's call it morning Brew for X right
where you you still have that
aggregation of summaries but you're more
Niche right and maybe the tab is smaller
but you think because of your tone and
because the way you cover it you can
have a larger percent of that Tam
reading your product which Sean I think
is what you're doing and the third is
more of like your classic hey I'm gonna
give you five links your five bullet
Friday or things like that I think the
biggest opportunity is Sean what you did
which is morning Brew for X you find a
growing industry and you just ride that
tail wave and you just own that and
build a brand something really distinct
in one of these you know if x is finance
or X's something that's more B2B or like
you know a professional you know
something that's a job title uh then X
works better than if x is you know fly
fishing or or or you know basketball or
something like that
yeah so I think if you're gonna go
consumer route right target consumers
it's got to be high dollar it's got to
be you know the newsletter for Ferrari
owners or the newsletter for Rolex
owners right something where people
spend you know hundreds of thousands of
dollars a year on this B2B is great as
well that's the other place I would go
and so you were kind of like I call it
maybe Pro summary right that was the
best of both worlds you could hit them
both worlds you got the consumer
oriented uh readers and then also the
people who work in the crypto industry
did you agree with our I know that I and
we actually did or I'll say it myself I
did sound like a douchebag when I was
talking about Industry Drive I didn't
mean to like phrase it that the way that
I did but when we were talking about
Industry Drive you know they're a 600
million dollar
a company that mostly is a newsletter
business and our criticism towards the
B2B industry was like the content's
pretty whack do you agree with that uh
that assessment like do you still think
there's a lot of opportunity to build
really big B2B media companies
yeah I just think you have to do it the
way Sean did it right which is go the
complete opposite route right so they're
they're pretty dry they have a
standardized process they go in every
single vertical look I think their
business model is simple but it's not
easy I don't think what they did was
easy at all but I think it's very simple
The Playbook is very well defined
there's no crazy Tech they're not you
know building some AI machine learning
thing it's they create great content
they resonate they sell ads into it uh
but the way to compete I think is to
treat B2B like consumer right to treat
them like people like you know the milk
row does why is it not you're saying
it's simple but not easy why is it not
what do you mean it's not easy I mean I
I think to scale across all those
verticals right to your point added
businesses are pretty tough right and so
you take on a lot of costs and you can't
you can't mess up right because if you
you go wrong in verticals you have a
bunch of writers and sales people and
and the thing about media business is
even when they're profitable the
difference between 20 uh profit margins
and losing 20 is way is way like it's
easier to flip that uh because of all
your fixed costs it's not SAS you don't
have locked in you know you're a B2B SAS
company you've locked in a hundred or a
hundred ten percent of your Revenue the
next year because of renewals every day
with ads it's another grind you got to
go sell more ads and so it's not easy
you know ad business is an absolute
grind we found this guy
um I'm gonna give a shout out here his
name's I don't know I think you
pronounce it Walter and he's from the
Netherlands and he uh I think he's at
school right now I don't know what
happened but I I did a video I thought
okay maybe maybe we'll start doing
YouTube content I did this video when
Luna collapsed and I did this video like
oh I lost a bunch of money on Luna and I
did this video I thought it was gonna be
like I remember buddy I was like a viral
whatever we came out late we came out
like three weeks after the news so that
was kind of stupid so it didn't go super
viral but one good thing came of it
which was this this kid on Twitter was
like hey your thumbnail sucks for for
your YouTube thing like it should be
like this or like this or like this he
did this thread and I was like yo you're
great
um I don't know if I'm gonna do any more
YouTube videos but like you want to just
come in our slack because I just want I
like what you just did that was like
helpful and it was quick and like you
know he's like sure yeah let me be
amazing I love the milk Road and so he
joins our slack
first we're like What do we do with this
guy like what the [__] is this guy like
imagine like a two-person meeting and I
just invite this third guy from the
Netherlands to a meeting you'd be like
uh like it's gonna talk what's why is he
here and for two months no one knew why
he was there but then something amazing
happened we were like ah we need to sell
ads like for the next month or whatever
and it was like nobody wanted to do it
it was just like
uh do we have to like it's gonna be a
pain in the ass it sucks it just sucks
to sell ads like oh we should hire a
sales guy it's like uh even hiring a
sales guy is kind of a shitty task okay
let's procrastinate a little bit
and uh
along the way this guy had been wanting
all right this guy had been always just
messaging us ideas like because he's
like I don't know he's like in the slack
so he's like trying to be productive so
he would just non-stop message ideas of
things we could do
and uh it got to the point where Ben was
just sort of like dude this guy is like
you know incessant like he won't stop
messaging it's like you know at first
it's a good but like nobody can handle
this volume of ideas like this is crazy
and then he's like he's like you got to
do something about this and I was like
okay I'll I don't know I'll talk to him
or I'll kick him out of slack and I was
like Hey what if we just point the
machine gun like outwards instead of
like right now the machine gun's
shooting us with ideas what if we just
made him like sell the ads and he just
bothered the hell out of everybody else
and so that's what we did and this guy
is the single-handedly crushing milk
Road ad sales through the crypto bear
market like we are fully sold out for
months on end
just one guy just one kid who's not even
20 years old just absolutely pillaging
the market and the advertisers will
privately DM me and be like yo I shared
this guy's name with our sales team
because I was like this is how you sell
like this guy is Relentless and I was
like wow that was just like an
incredible I don't know like incredible
thing he is so impressive
dude let's talk about that real quick ad
sales ad sales suck Austin they suck and
what I learned getting into the hustle I
I did you sell I sold our first ads I
think I got us I sold like the first
maybe hundred thousand dollars worth of
ads and then in order to scale we had to
hire a sales team and they would show me
like the conversations that they are
gonna have I'm like there's this
conversation will never work like you're
using all this jargon and you're wearing
like these like buttoned up plaid shirts
and like these brown leather shoes like
you guys look like dweebs like this is
never gonna work and it worked perfectly
nobody wants to go skateboarding with
you right now yeah you're not ready
you look like your name's Todd or Kyle
like this is not gonna work and uh it's
like my name is it [__] works yeah
yeah it works perfectly you're you're
not cut out your personal is not cut out
for the the media buying world did you
do it you're uh well no so yeah in the
early days we bought right but we we
sold all direct response ads right it
was Casper mattress it was a way luggage
it was saying no hey buy your placement
here you're gonna get
300 clicks and three percent of them
convert and you're gonna make a thousand
dollars and we'll charge you 800. as
we've grown though I think there's
another difference between us we were in
New York City and it opened up this
whole world that I had no idea about
which was the world of of media buying
and these big ad agencies and they have
huge budgets right we're not talking
about a hundred grand for Casper we're
talking about five million dollars from
the biggest brands in the entire world
and it really is a black box of people
who aren't in it and I think it's one of
those things where it's a black box
intentionally so people can't get in
right Finance is the same thing every
year there's a new term within the ad
industry or Finance just to keep people
on the Internet it's crazy it's crazy
and it's like not based in logic or fact
it's based on relationships and like
it's so weird it's like oh wait I have
to realize that this person this lady
I'm trying to get to buy ads she just
has to spend this 20 million dollars
this quarter and she just wants to find
somewhere to place it where she won't
get fired that was such a weird feeling
yeah I mean the idea of like media
budgets right hey they if they if they
don't use it they lose it and so you're
incentivized to spend money it's it's
interesting and it's uh something that
we learned Again by hiring people in New
York which I think was a big difference
between us and you you had a lower cost
more like inside sales team a really
efficient one right you took that route
we didn't take that route we went for
these Big Brand dollars and and I think
both routes work it depends what you're
what you're looking to sell um we just
took the route and say hey we're gonna
we're gonna Dive Right In this black box
and we're gonna learn all about it we're
gonna get a million I mean one of our
first advertisers discover gave us a
million bucks I was in college I'm a
senior in college living in my frat
house right like beer cans everywhere
and I get an email from the CMO discover
like here's an RFP I'm like what in the
[__] is an RFP like what are you talking
about no clue I open it up and it's like
hey give us media plans for like half a
million a million bucks right for a
million dollars she could own the
company seven times over the company was
not worth 100 grand and and here's this
woman asking for a million dollar RFP
and we just we learned it but it really
is a relationship driven game how did
you how did you justify that like how do
you like if if if AMX says we're going
to spend five million dollars this year
be real do you actually think that's
going to help them like sell more [__]
yeah so I I do right we do a lot of
brand lift studies and things like that
right it's different right it's not
we're not no one's trying to uh you know
like Lexus for example or car company
studies did you do
we used to do that but I'd be like what
the [__] is a brand live study like I'm
like are you kidding me Todd what the
hell is a brand live study I don't know
what the hell this is or we would do all
this other stuff like an RFP like we had
been doing it for like six months and I
was like Hey guys like at this point I'm
a little bit too afraid to ask but what
the hell is it RFP
I don't know what this stuff means I
didn't know what any of this stuff it's
so challenging if you don't work in the
industry and then they like they talk
about agencies and I'm like wait what
the hell it is an agency why don't we
just go straight to the brand like this
stuff from it from a small business
owner's perspective all of this stuff is
crazy inefficient and stupid now that
I've been at a big company HubSpot I
understand I'm like okay I get like
these guys are having to like give out a
billion dollars of marketing like now I
I understand a lot more but when you're
just a 10 person company you're like do
you guys realize this Market study [__]
doesn't work like this brand study
that's [__] right or like you're
gonna give me twenty thousand dollars to
write this article it took me like 20
minutes to do it uh like so it doesn't
make sense when you're small yeah but
you know people are people are buying
the audience they're buying the the
relationship with with you they're not
buying you know purchase or things like
that and so you know I think at scale
when you get to four million subscribers
if you can change the perception
of half a million or a million people
and have make them because of a
marketing campaign have a you know 10 of
people have a higher perception of of
credit card X's programs like that is
really valuable when your Visa or your
master or your American Express and you
spend a billion dollars like that's so
much money how do you deploy a billion
dollars of marketing spend you go
through agencies and that's how it all
happens
Sean and I are really good I think at
starting stuff we've got pretty good
Vision where we can spin things up and
get them to like a million in Revenue
pretty quickly the thing that I was
always envious of you because it's my
it's a it's a fairly big shortcoming I
think I have is you are just so good at
I don't know exactly how to explain it
you've got this like almost private
Equity like ability to like look at
numbers and be like oh the margin here
is shitty and I'm like I've never used
that word margin in my life but you'll
like talk about like the margin here and
like well if you just change that by
like 10 probably by doing this your
outcome is going to be like this this
and this like you just have this really
good operational ability you're also
really good at saying like well if you
just improve this this and this and only
focus on that then in six months I think
your outcome will be this you're really
good at that and you're really good at
that at a very young age how did you
figure out how to do that how did you
learn how to do that and and have that
insight and have that ability and also
have that faith in like well if you just
do this this and this the outcome might
be this this and this in eight months
yeah I mean so I got an undergraduate
business degree and I always used to
[__] on undergraduate business degrees
I'm like what a complete waste of time
like those four years were so dumb but
as I look back it really did give me a
pretty good overview of what it takes to
to run a business not actually the
day-to-day of running a business but
like what is accounting I took like
seven accounting classes or I don't know
maybe five those were actually really
valuable to be able to really dive deep
into a p l to real and my summer
expensive Investment Banking to
understand what's a financial model what
drives the model those things that
within the context of Finance like yeah
you know they're okay when the context
of running a business was super helpful
to understand what levers you need to
pull but the other the flip side is I
looked at you three years ago and I
before we knew each other maybe even two
years ago and I was like both of you I
was like I hate these guys because
they're so good at going zero to one
they're so good at coming up with ideas
like I'm the opposite right I'm not an
ideas guy I can't come up with ideas but
I do think it is there cooler and sexier
to do what we do do you know listen
there's no doubt about that it's
definitely yeah like dude what would you
I mean you know we don't we need to like
partner because zero to one is cool but
then like one to 100 million years is
pretty [__] cool too yeah how about
you guys take things you get them off
the ground you take them to three
employees and a million dollars of
Revenue and I'll take it from one to a
hundred and we can just pair up in just
everything about his margin and he
thought I said margarine he brought me
some butter
dude like like I didn't understand what
we know for all we know the the hustle
was either a billion dollar company or
worthless
um Sam says no idea yeah well I like I
remember
um when we were negotiating to sell and
like there was just all these things
that people were giving me advice on and
I'm like man I just didn't even think
about that like it's just and I actually
know a lot of people that are really
successful like we're talking billion
dollars successful and they know so
little about operations and there's a
lot of people like that like who are
just they're good at hiring Like Richard
Branson I think he famously said he's
like dude I didn't know what a p l was
until we hit like hundreds of millions
of Revenue like I didn't know how to
read it
um
which is super cool uh so awesome you
what I like uh that you said on the
operation side like Sam's saying is um
like you when you were talking earlier
you were like you know right gross sell
we wrote that on the wall we woke up
every day and said right gross sell we
had the greatest so good at that those
are the things that like uh we I used to
do this such like similar like literally
we had the wall but not with milk Road
actually but this is like kind of my
earlier startups and at Monkey Alfredo I
remember Sam you probably remember this
when people used to come in like we
would always have like all this [__] on
the walls and like these sayings and
these posters indoctrination things the
indoctrination and and I always felt
like whenever I would meet Founders one
of the highest predictors of success was
do they even know what the main thing is
and it sounds like a stupid question
but for a lot of Founders they didn't
really understand what the main thing
was for their business they didn't know
their business's version of right
grossell okay and even if they
understood like that that's gonna
generic okay what are you gonna do with
that they didn't understand to translate
that into the Great Wall of opens is the
number we're gonna write down every day
we're going to look at it and if it's
bad we're gonna do something about it
and if it's good we're gonna like double
down on that and that's what daily work
is is around this one number and so it
was like I remember we had these
Founders in in the office and they would
be like I'd be like all right what's the
you know how many new customers you guys
get today like what's the revenue
and they have to like oh yeah let me
check and they would like at first they
didn't have a dashboard they're like
going into the database like bro you
haven't built an easy way to know this
number and then then finally they built
that and they always had to check and I
was like how do you not know why am I
asking this question like it's 3 P.M one
of y'all two should have asked this
question by 3 P.M like every day this is
crazy
and they just didn't do it and I was
like these guys are gonna fail because
they don't have to keep the main thing
the main thing
is that something that you see or like
did consciously like where'd you get
that because that wasn't uh obvious to
be right out of college but it sounds
like you got it right right away
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
yeah that I mean for us
I I mean it's almost an insult right we
were we people like why didn't you do
this why don't you do that why don't you
go into video we were too dumb to do
that like we had no we're like video how
the hell do you make a video we can
barely get our newsletter out I mean
there were days where we'd we'd finish
the newsletter like 2 A.M we'd be coding
the thing ourselves and so I think it
was partially you know a little bit of
foresight but also partially a forcing
function uh you know we just looked at
we're like if we do these things we will
get here and we looked at the math and
we're like everyone's telling us we're
crazy but if we grow Subs fifty thousand
dollars every or 50 000 subscribers
every single month and our costs don't
change
we're gonna go from 50 000 monthly
Revenue to 75 to 100 to 125 and by end
of this year we're gonna be at a million
Subs doing a million dollars of Revenue
a month and I tell that to investors and
people they'd be like that doesn't make
any sense I'm like I don't know what to
tell you like I'm just looking at the
Excel and people could I mean we spoke
to investors and they were like what do
you mean your business only has a
hundred thousand dollars of costs I'm
like it's people it's growth marketing
and it's an ESP that's it that's all we
spend money on what was that last line I
don't even know what that last line is
email it's like provider email service
provider will you sail through oh ESP
yeah okay I think I said yeah I was like
SP I was like what the hell is sp okay
yeah but it's it's one of those things
where like it was just when you boil it
down to numbers and run it in an Excel
model it's like it's so simple and
people these investors were like well
like you're not accounting for this and
that I'm like it's all [__] like
none of that means anything I'm just
trying to make money like I'm just
trying to also did some Scrappy stuff I
remember like uh didn't you get your
first I don't know a few thousand emails
just by like standing in a classroom
I I think we may have we may have broken
a couple laws to get our first couple
thousand people want to walk out you'd
have a piece of paper and be like hey
just write your email now we we wouldn't
let him walk out so we go in the
beginning of a lecture these econ 101
lectures like a thousand people and I
hated Publix I still do but I hated
public speaking and I was like look if
I'm going to this lecture hall and I've
been talking from a thousand people I
better get every damn email and so what
I would do is I'd speak in front of
these people and I'd walk around like
the teacher would let you speak or you
would just stand up yeah no no the
teacher would let us speak because
there's a thing called Michigan times
you actually had 10 minutes in between
each class so if the class started at 10
it actually started at 10 10. and so at
1005 I get up there I pitch on Pitch
them one morning brew and then I
basically print out an Excel document
and I'd walk around I would just stand
in front of people and just stare them
in the eyes until they gave me their
email and I sit in the back of the class
and type every email in and I'd be like
[__] Alex that an A or a c or an e he'd
be like who cares put them all in and
we've had like every like six
permutations of every single email and
that's how we got to like 10 or 15 000
at Michigan and then we're like
do you have a friend of Penn State I
have a friend at Penn State let's do
this at Penn State let's do it at Miami
let's do it at NYU and next thing you
know we like 50 000 people across the
the country college students reading
morning Brew are your parents wealthy
did you grow up wealthy
uh I'd say middle class upper middle
class but what's interesting so I grew
up in the suburbs of Baltimore and like
I didn't know I thought I knew wealth
and then I moved to I went to Michigan
and I met people from LA and New York
and I moved to New York and I saw people
from New York and I never saw that kind
of wealth and to me that was inspiring
that was exciting uh because I came from
again there's like a very well-off I had
everything I needed but you know I know
people I met people at school who were
flying private planes I know what a
private plane was you got rich pretty
young right like when did you guys sell
you're you're pretty young right now I
think you guys sold it what 26 or
something yeah I need 25. well the
reason but hold on real quick the reason
I asked was because like you've got this
like this immigrant hustle and before I
knew you I stereotyped you as this like
uh everything's been given to this rich
kid like and and hearing this story I'm
like oh no these guys were like just as
gritty as I was for sure sometimes more
um yeah I mean Alex has his own story
about you know his family and and his
dad passed away and so he was I mean I
learned so much from Alex about Hunger
like Alex again he broke things down the
same way I did Alex would be like hey
you know I'd be like Alex we need a
hundred advertisers this year I'd be
like I don't know how we're gonna do it
we have zero he goes I know exactly how
we'll do it I'm gonna go on LinkedIn and
I'm not gonna sleep until I message a
thousand companies and we'll get a 10
reply rate I'll be like you're gonna
message a thousand companies he's like
well isn't that what you need to do to
get to 100 100 advertisers I'd be like
yeah but that sounds crazy he goes well
let's start working and we just like you
know sit there drink beer and we work
and just you know crank out cold DMS the
head of I mean I must know the head of
growth at every New York City direct to
Consumer company because Alex
incessantly emailed them and we would
like we would laugh at the response like
we would get excited when someone
respond to be like hey Alex this is your
ninth email like you gotta stop
following up like number eight was good
but nine you you passed it so yeah I
think we both had that hustle what did
it feel like the back to what Sean was
saying you're 25 and you I don't know
how much one you made but let's just say
eight figures what's that feel like when
you're 25
um
[__] dope
it was very cool it's great
so so it's so it's interesting right
um I I got the wire this is what the the
sum of money I was it was during covid
so I get this like listen to this
juxtaposition on one hand I just made a
boatload of money more money than you
know I thought I'd ever make right
on the other hand I'm living in my
childhood bedroom
sitting next to my parents as the wire
hits my account and everyone's like what
are you gonna do now I was like I don't
know my mom's cooking like meatloaf yeah
mom make me breakfast
yeah it was the most anti-climactic
thing ever it was unbelievably
anticlimactic you should have just moved
into the master bedroom
I think uh getting a quick win early or
a win early in life is so important
right just having that Swagger that
confidence that brand allows me to do so
much that I wouldn't have been able to
do otherwise but
get into any room I can get in touch
with anyone right what other
opportunities do you think you get I
mean again like get into any room right
so meetings uh investing what are some
what are some cool rooms you got into I
mean again like it's the same things
that I think you guys are you guys also
have wins right I don't think anything
is is that well I don't like to leave my
house and then Sam's only interested in
like people that are like this guy's the
best ax thrower in you know the country
and he's like super pumped about it I'm
like I don't think you needed to like
you know pull your your you know rich
guy card to get in touch with him but I
feel like you I don't know like like
have you met Leo DiCaprio I feel like he
might have just bumped into Leo DiCaprio
somewhere that I feel like that's more
Europe in New York well so so I I bumped
into Justin Bieber in the Bahamas
um which was pretty cool
um but no I mean like the weekend we had
with with uh uh what's his name Mr Beast
and and uh hosted was cool I spent the
weekend with Kid Rock on his Ranch yeah
tell me about it was pretty sick what
was that like
I mean he is a a unique unique character
again this is all according to him so I
haven't even fact checked this but I'll
assume he's telling the truth he told me
he's the only person to play at both
President Obama and president Trump's
inaugurations he played it both and he
knows both super well he's close to both
and he has this this he lives in this
huge Ranch outside of Nashville right I
went there it was uh my friend his
name's Shane uh he works in Tech he's
good friends with Kid Rock Kid Rock
obviously music guy and Shane put
together 10 people in Tech Kid Rock 10
people in music we go to his Ranch and I
mean you get there and it's like out of
a movie right you walk in and Kid Rock's
bats is to me he's got a cigar sticking
out of his mouth he's got a shotgun and
he's just shooting clay pigeons and the
whole weekend was out of a movie right
his Studio unbelievable we pull no
lighter together just telling stories
about Eminem uh I mean he's uh it is
really really cool he's a lot of people
don't realize this but Kid Rock got
famous right before CDs went down and
he's one of the best-selling artists of
all time and I I it wouldn't surprise me
if he's probably worth two or three
hundred million dollars because he was
famous when CDs were 18 and 21 and so
like it's wild yeah so now though I
think he's a new source of wealth so he
owns uh again this is what I've been
told he owns the most popular bar in all
of Nashville and whereas most of the
other ones like Luke Bryant has one and
a bunch of other country singers they
just license their name to the bar right
and they make a couple percent I think
Kid Rock's like a 50 50 owner probably
makes two million bucks a month
no I've heard more really like it's a
project I've heard again I've heard it's
big big money you know high high uh tens
of millions you know it's just crazy
dude the one of the best things uh about
our companies and um like the culture
that us three have kind of built with
our friends because we kind of like got
into this media game a little bit early
and I don't know about you Austin but
when the hustle was starting there
wasn't that many people who we could
look at and be like well let's just do
what they do but different they're like
I remember I told this one media guy who
I'll tell you afterwards he's the
founder of a multi-billion dollar Media
company now I was like here's what I'm
doing he goes bro this will never make
more than two million dollars a year in
revenue and this other person who I'm
now good friends with was like dude what
are you talking about this I'm like it
doesn't matter it's just a small screen
who cares like if you're an email or on
a website it doesn't matter the math
shows X Y and Z and so we had to hire
like 24 year olds who like were
promising but like and then we had to
learn about it as we grew and be but
because of that both morning Brew the
hustle and the and the crew that now I
mean Sean's great at this as well we've
we've done a really cool job of like
finding smart inexperienced people who
now have gone on to do a lot of really
cool stuff and that makes me really
really proud to like see like this crew
that we've all built and so there's like
the hustle crew the morning Brew Crew
and then uh Sean was like the hustle
thing now he's got his own thing have
you noticed that like we all have this
little like
Army of people who have like been
through like this like self-created like
training camp it's kind of neat right
yeah 100 I mean it's it's we in the
early days we could not get people to
work with us who didn't want to be
entrepreneurs and the pitch was simply
like Hey we're starting a business
you'll be in on the ground floor right
you'll see what it's like and that's
that's all you get like you know we
didn't have for the first year and a
half I was so cheap for the first year
and a half of morning Brew you didn't
get a company computer you had to bring
your own computer to work dude I was
famous because on Facebook I would put
hey I'm buying I'm buying laptops does
anyone have a Mac for sale for 500
no dude we were not dropping any money
on company we didn't have health care in
the early days you got nothing you got I
mean and we we couldn't afford it
because I was so against taking venture
capital I was like we're gonna make
every penny count One More Story Fridays
at three o'clock we'd all go pencils
down work would stop because we had a
referral program we'd send out stickers
and t-shirts and that whole thing that
you know I'm sure we've all seen
but yeah we had no we know packing and
so we'd sit down we'd like wheel in that
we were keg into our office and we'd
conveyor you know we do like assembly
line the first person would would like
open the envelope the next person would
stick the sticker in there the next
person would lick them the next person
would put the the label on and for like
three or four hours from like 3 P.M till
7 pm on Fridays that's all we did was
just pack envelopes of [__] well you're
one of your early Guys Tyler dank has
gone on to start beehive which is a
really cool company he seemed like a
really good entrepreneur he's pivoting
or um iterating really quickly and then
I've got a couple people have done that
and then um like it's just cool to see
like these people who were young and not
dumb but like just young and like
inexperienced go on to like build cool
[__] and then like your ex people are
now at other newsletter companies and
then Sean has hired a couple of my ex
people or and probably it seems like a
couple of your ex people and it's like
this incestuous thing which at first I
would be jealous I'm like whoa what the
hell why are they working with this
person but now I'm like oh this is
awesome man like we've created this like
tiny little industry of of newsletter
nerds and it's actually quite cool
yeah I love it yeah I think it's really
cool and I think there's gonna be so
much more value create I think what
Tyler's doing at beehive is amazing I
think what I've been so impressed with
him is like the the maturation from the
morning Brew days of you know it's like
six of us and he's doing a little bit of
everything so the way he's been able to
scale himself and scale that team is
amazing and so it's really and I mean
Trung is the same way like what Trung's
done is incredible and there's I mean
there's a ton of examples it's really
cool to see do you regret selling
no
that's that's you answered that quickly
even though like not even so you sold
part of the business what do you think
the the entire business is going to sell
for in the future
hundreds of millions I think many
multiples of what we sold the first uh
half four but we structured the deal in
a way that I thought was great right I
mean the ability to have life-changing
money if anyone has the option like I
always think it's good to take half your
chips off the table right and maybe I'm
biased because I did that and and it's
worked I thought that was really
important but I still have enough upside
where I'm excited right it's not like a
tiny earn out that people sign where
it's like 10 of the deal it can you know
it can be really really meaningful and
that drives me that keeps me excited it
keeps me on the hunt
I love the company I love the people we
work with I love the executive team but
I would I I mean during covet or during
I wouldn't have slept at night and I
just I sleep very well at night knowing
that like I have my my nest egg and so
what'd you do with money do you think
cool with it or do you uh did you touch
it right away what that money hits the
bank you're at your parents house
what it what happened to that money over
the next I don't know how long it's been
like a year or two
yeah so I haven't ideally in terms of
everyone's like oh yeah like make a
Splurge purchase there was nothing out
there that I was that excited about
buying so I ended up buying a car on
which expensive I didn't buy like a
Mercedes I bought an Acura right nothing
crazy
yeah
a pre-owned Acura
it wasn't Frio and brand new 2022.
sports mode sports edition
Air Conditioning that's air conditioning
what why dude you really do have that
immigrant mentality but I think we need
to get you like a 23andMe test I I feel
like uh there's something going on here
you got too much immigrant energy I love
it
no but I mean I I I increased my rent
four to five times right I live in a
great apartment
um I went on an amazing vacation last
summer
um you know I I actually love I know you
guys know ramit's uh States here sethia
I'm not sure I pronounced last name but
like that idea of like your rich life
and your spending on because I mean uh
lifestyle creep is real totally that is
real and so like look I spend money on
the things that I find interesting and
that I like and I love traveling and
staying at really nice hotels and
spending a ton of money on business
class flights and things like that I
like living a nice apartment but like I
live in New York City what am I going to
do drop another 50k on a car that sits
in a parking lot
361 days a year it's a complete waste of
money it's just stupid and
you know I Morgan Howells will actually
tweeted this
um and I read this too it Will Smith's
book he has a great quote he was talking
about Fame and becoming famous and the
quote was something like
becoming famous is awesome being famous
is cool and losing any Fame is horrible
and I feel the same exact way about
money right I feel the same way and so I
have no desire to like spend money on
things I don't actually care about I
don't wanna I don't want to lose my
money because I can you know change the
a to a you know an M or whatever on a
Mercedes so I spend money that I on
things I actually care about so I can
make sure I maintain my wealth or what
do you invested or do you just are you
conservative are you aggressive like
what's the pie chart of like
of the hundred percent where did it
where did the money go
yeah so I probably took like 85 90 of it
and put it into very very boring stuff
right S P 500 or Vanguard like Target
date funds like uh 20 65 or something
like that you did this yourself or you
hired like a well personally no I hired
a team it's a good thing I did because
if not I would have went off the rails
right
um and then I put you know five maybe
seven percent in crypto right and I put
another five percent in Venture
investing right uh but the vast vast
majority is in really boring real estate
S P 500 uh and
uh like bonds right but like really
boring [__] nice and let's talk about
some non-newsletter stuff so
you got a bunch of ideas uh when we were
hanging out at Camp MFM uh you were
telling me about like this thing you're
doing and this thing you're doing I was
like oh this guy's like way more Dynamic
uh and interested in a whole bunch of
different things what are some ideas
that you think would be cool to share
yeah
um so I'll throw out a bunch of ideas I
have but one General framework I think
people should think about is when you're
in shitty Economic Times like we're
going into now I think the the framework
you should use is you should look to
save companies money or earn individuals
side income right before companies money
didn't matter right Capital was abundant
so companies they were all about just
grow grow right how can you help me grow
it's a 180 now you know people were
trading their money for others people
other people's time right now they're
trading time for money and so all you
know if you can help companies preserve
money you can I think build really
really great side hustles so a few ideas
right I think it's like what's old is
new and then there's a bunch of agencies
I think it'd be really interesting to
start right now one is outsourced Talent
I knew nothing about the outsourced
Talent game I recently became a co-owner
in a business uh it's a really
interesting business called oceans they
found talent in Sri Lanka right really
cool talent in Sri Lanka where they've
U.S graduates uh come to Tech startups
work there uh really interesting and I
think there are ways right they have a
unique Advantage going to Sri Lanka
which we don't really have to talk about
but I think there are companies who were
hiring a full-time copywriter let's call
it or a full-time uh you know marketer
and they probably only need them for 25
30 hours a week 2021 screw it right
we'll need them at some point I think
now companies are really questioning
ftes right do you need a full-time hire
and so you can create these Niche
marketplaces and I'm getting investment
opportunities for them all the time and
they're just not Venture scaled but you
bootstrap a Marketplace let's call it
like a Content marketing uh agency or
content marketing Marketplace for B2B
companies right these stocks are down 90
95 they're trying to drop ftes but they
still want content right we all know how
valuable only audience and content is
and building that Marketplace helping
them find people I think simple services
like that are going to come back and to
Vogue and be very very profitable
what's that company
um where the founder got in trouble for
not converting the the stock uh
converting the convertible notes but it
was a Marketplace for uh developers and
it like bootstrapped its way uptown
practically it was a top towel so top
towel um
they got in trouble because they only
raised like 800 000 or a million dollars
but they didn't convert the the the the
the note or whatever so it was
controversial but they basically have
bootstrapped it to this point to like
north of a 100 million in net revenue
um and so these marketplaces are like
can be they can be pretty freaking
powerful it seem they seemed hard to get
off the ground but they don't seem that
hard if you already working in in the
industry and it's a super Niche a niche
topic because people ask me all the time
they go hey I want to hire writers who
should I hire and I'm like I don't know
man it's hard I don't know who you
should hire yeah
yeah I mean the one I the one I'm now a
co-owner and has gone from zero to seven
figures of ARR in like eight months
right you pick a very specific Target
customer that's a gross unique talent
gross or is that just yeah margins are
no no well now both right both are seven
figures of ARR that's crazy
yeah and then uh what's his name
Marshall from uh Marshall Haas he did
Shepard what's the URL that's the same
thing right it's the same same business
and I I it seems like he's scaled that
to high seven figures in like less than
a year it seems from the outside yeah
yeah I think they're a bit different
right ours is I think they're just more
like strictly EAS the one we have is
more you you know you have people in
finance people in operations what's
interesting about Sri Lanka is they have
big four accounting firms right so you
can poach people not just from local
businesses but from people who've been
trained by Ernst young and and Deloitte
and so it's an interesting an
interesting demographic to go into
yeah I love that one I think that's a
great one what are uh what are some
other like you know help businesses save
money help you the other one you said is
help individuals earn side money what's
a what's an example of that yeah so
here's one I think is interesting right
so you built morning Brew for crypto
right I know a lot of people spoken
about this but I don't think anyone's
really built the brand yet I think
morning Brew or the hustle for AI is
gonna be huge but how's that feel by the
way a thing you're just like calling
Sean the morning Brew of blank it's okay
it's okay we did kick your ass to crypto
I mean it's okay it's okay that that
happened no you we can test Let It Go
though we could tell we could take a
collective deep breath and just let it
go if you if that would help no no again
you guys did a really great job I
thought that was awesome
um and I think someone's gonna do the
same thing in AI right and so the
bootstrap version of this is to do what
you did right the AI newsletter right
down the Fairway have a unique tone
integrate yourself into the audience the
way I think is take it to the next level
is the last three months thousands of
entrepreneurs have all started tinkering
on little AI side projects right and
they all have 50 100K of ARR and I've
been reaching out to all these Founders
like you know
um different little tools right these
aren't real big businesses they're all
side hustles right I went home for
Thanksgiving I asked all my friends from
home my family Haley have you guys been
playing around with the chat GPT have
you been playing around and they're like
what in the hell are you talking about
right and so clearly it's the same
customer for all of these different
things right and so I think there's this
opportunity for the AI for morning Brew
to start a little tiny capital or a
little holding company where you can
start to invest and buy these businesses
right give a an off ramp these Founders
who built these 50 or 100 or 150k Arrow
businesses and start cross-promoting
them bundling marketing them you write
reviews for your little AI tool and then
you promote it and instead of having
advertising which Again Sam has spoken
about how it's difficult you're just
promoting all your products you have
this portfolio of 10 20 30 little AI
tools and maybe each one is half a
million or a million of ARR but all
together you can get you get pretty big
pretty quickly
that one seems harder to me
um I I feel like
like I like the idea but with Mike okay
realistically if I did that I feel like
I would uh I like ideas where the idea
is so good my execution can be like a
seven out of ten and I still win
um because yeah but this is his thing
man this is his thing he he executes
some of these things really well yeah
yeah I don't think it'd be that hard I'm
telling you I I've been talking to a
bunch of these like these Founders these
little AI SCI projects and I've been I'm
like what are you doing with it and
they're like well at least I think it's
hard is not because you can't roll them
up you can't buy them I think it's hard
because
uh all it's like the Lindy effect right
so when something's been around for
three months is that 50k mrr and it
seems great like you don't know if that
thing's gonna be around three months
from now because the next model will
come out or the next chat like for
example uh you know
your stable diffusion comes out then and
then uh you know chat GPT comes out well
people were you know I've invested in a
couple of these that you know the AI
writing tools they're getting better
and they're pouring Millions into
marketing to get to get customers for
their you know AI writing tool but
everybody's building on the same
foundations the same models and they're
trying to say how they're going to be
differentiated and the reality is they
could differentiate it on I don't know
customer acquisition and so I think that
like it is
you know I think about when I buy
something like you know the tiny Capital
model works because he buys stuff that's
like kind of been like around and
forgotten and ignored for like a long
period of time but he buys like you know
dribble
um you know it's like oh it's been
around for years and I could buy it and
I can it's gonna be around for years and
I can improve it over that time uh
versus buying the things that are really
new and quick I think you have a
challenge with the durability
um of those businesses because what
happens as
you know the AI just keeps improving but
you know either these things become
obsolete or it starts to consolidate
into like one app that can do four of
these things and so you don't need one
for posting on social media and one for
writing emails it's like ah it's the
same Chrome extension that's just gonna
do both and so I think there's a good
chance you can kind of get like
you know um
you know just sort of Blown Away by by
the rate of change that's going on in
the industry so that's the thing I would
be worried about with that similar to I
remember telling Andrew Wilkinson about
frazio I was like oh this is super smart
like these FBA stores are super cheap
and there's you know like each one of
them is small
but you could go and just like scoop up
all these and look at this they're
buying them on this like crazy little
multiple agos yeah it's like picking
pennies up in front of a steamroller and
um is his first reaction and I was like
yeah I can see what you mean what like
if the platform changes he goes
if anything happens he's like you know
these aren't real durable Brands I
haven't been around for a while maybe
it's that Amazon changes the algorithm
maybe it's that there's you know more
competition maybe it's not the multiples
go up there's there's four or five
different ways where you just get
steamrolled and that's actually what how
it played out pretty much in the in the
Amazon aggregator space was for a while
the getting was good and then those
companies went all in on it and then
they kind of got steamrolled that you
know they're getting steamrolled as we
speak
yeah I think you bring up a great point
about AI right and that's why well I
think the technology is great I've been
very skeptical of investing in these
companies that just really build on top
of uh you know open AI because it's like
you have a nice wrapper right it's nice
marketing it's great but what do you
have long term what do you actually can
all do that what are you gonna do who
doesn't do that nobody's doing their own
AI everybody's everybody's building off
open AI or stable diffusion and that's
why I'm skeptical investing in that
right I I think there's so many popping
up right it's the next crypto wave right
there's gonna be a huge huge bubble and
you know and they're raising not at
crypto prices but I'm seeing hey two
guys left some you know Andrew recent
back company we're raising 5 on 25 like
what do you have they're like oh well we
have a deck but since we created the
deck we've already changed our mind it
was this and now it's this it's like
guys you can't he can't be serious we've
seen this playoffs while you say that
they're like we just got another offer
for 35 the price is gone
you uh you know like I always I I always
felt this way about you and as I've got
to know you I feel this way even more
the way that you know someone's an
interesting founder is when you talk to
them and you're like a little fearful of
them where you're like I don't want to
have to go against this person because
they're going to be very very
challenging to kill and you totally have
that Vibe you've got this like weird
mixture of neuroticism where you're like
no I have to go like I have to win we're
gonna lose like this everything's over
if I don't win this thing but then you
also have this like really good work
ethic I remember I asked you the other
day I'm like hey at what point at
morning Brew did you quit grinding and
you're like what never I'm still
grinding and uh I think that's just a
really that's really fascinating
um are you weirdly good at like some
random thing did you like channel that
Obsession towards some other thing yeah
like growing up we like we tennis or
some [__]
yeah I mean I was obsessed with video
games right Sports video games uh but
nothing nothing specific right I wasn't
like Travis kalanick like number two we
tennis in the world
um no it was that and now I'm like into
that for cooking right I'm I've thought
about like when I go to culinary school
and take night classes because now I'm
obsessed with cooking I love to go out
did not see that coming do you gotta
come over for a meal you gotta come to
me I know you don't leave San Francisco
but when you do yeah
so what what do you uh what's you said
something about where me in like your
rich life what do you think your rich
life how old are you now 28 what's your
rich life gonna be at 35 and 40. like
what are you working towards yeah I I
think
for me uh it's all about time right like
to me wealth is all about having time
and spending that time how you want to
right now I want to spend that time
building this company because I
constantly see more growth and more
opportunity and not just like 2x but 10x
But ultimately what I wouldn't be able
to do at 35 is spend my time how I want
to spend it on any given day right and
and that means a lot of travel I love
traveling like I I want to go at some
point uh in the not too distant future
hopefully don't want a six-month trip
three months to Europe three months of
Southeast Asia I never got to do that a
lot of my friends in college when they
graduated they went to Thailand and
wherever else I drove from Michigan to
New York and started working the next
day and so for me it's a lot of
traveling you know nothing crazy spend
time with family doing fun stuff right
like being able just to say hey like
today I'm gonna you know drop 500 bucks
and go you know do something you know
the thousand dollars and go do some fun
activity right adventurous activities
but it'll all comes back just waking up
and say hey here's how I want to spend
my day and then doing that thing are you
able to do that now
I can right but I choose to spend that
time on Maureen Brew like I am
maniacally focused on growing morning
Brew I think there's a ton of
opportunity but as soon as I don't think
that like I'll change I'll say Hey you
know today I want to do something else
do you like having 200 plus employees it
sounds like [__] hell particularly
New York Manhattan like woke employees
that like in the New York media scene
like everyone's talking about unionizing
like when I think about that I'm like
this sounds miserable blink if Blake if
it's miserable because I know you can't
say anything what are you gonna say
um no no I I mean look and there's a
couple things one uh we have a lot of
remote employees so we do have a really
good distribution of employees across
the country which I think does help
right I think having employees
everywhere gives different perspectives
right our engineering team lives uh you
know in the midwest then and we have
people all across the country which I
think is cool uh but to be honest as a
CEO of a 250 person company I'm not
interacting with that many people on a
daily basis but what I love is like the
one of the reasons I Stay is because we
built this team of people who are
reporting to me who are just a plus
All-Stars like absolute rock stars and
that's what makes me so happy is when I
can just come to work and say Hey you
know Chief content officer hey you know
person X like what are you doing like
tell me more about it how can I help you
but also I'm like a vacuum right I'll
hire someone new a chief content officer
a COO I'll be like I'm gonna learn as
much as humanly possible and my goal is
to catch up to you and knowledge as fast
as possible so if you're 38 you're 40
you know you're you're 10 years older
than me I want to just vacuum up those
10 years of knowledge you've gained
working in these four or five places in
the next like two months and I'm just
gonna pester you and sit with you and
just learn as much as humanly possible
so I can you know be better than you and
know more than you and it's like this
competitive nature
that's exactly what I'm saying about
being like someone that you're you're
you'd be really hard to compete with you
were hard to compete with uh that's a
really fascinating mindset it's very
intriguing I saw Sean smirk that's
always a good sign
you're like yeah I wouldn't want to
compete with you it's like oh you did
for like five years I did yeah and like
uh I mean it was fun I I think that I
think maybe I'm the same way where
someone's like I don't know if I want to
compete to consume but but like you know
I think it's um
it's it's it's you're you're intriguing
you're interesting I think you have got
a really good mindset I think you got
that good inner game
yeah I I think I think I I can't refresh
this before but I think the thing that
really I I've changed my thinking about
you so much is I used to think you were
like rude and now yeah we've been
working together on like a few side
projects and what I've learned is that
your style is not for everyone but you
are what I would call like
admirably abrasive right and we wrote a
call I don't know if I'm supposed to
tell a story I won't say names we're on
a call and this guy gives us like a
three minute pitch and I just see the
look on Sam's face I go oh no this guy's
Spiel is not good and the guy goes Sam
what do you think and Sam no smile
straight face goes I don't know why I'm
even on this call what are you talking
about
well I just start dying but but I'm not
trying to be rude I'm not trying to be
rude exactly exactly and it's not for
everyone right that style is not for
everyone but I can see how you so
quickly grow things with the right
people because that type of radical
Candor that like hey I'm just gonna tell
you what I think and we're not gonna
have an ego and we're gonna work
together to solve problems is so much
better than sitting in the corporate
media being like Oh yeah no that was
that was great and then sending an email
later you should look this guy straight
in the eyes and you're like I don't know
why I'm here yeah I mean and the person
who we're speaking with I think they're
great and I was just like you're you're
great this is stupid though you you know
be different and uh be better than you
are right now and achieve your potential
I think you're I think you're great
that's typically the way that I work
with people and I don't like hearing
when people say that I'm rude that kind
of hurts my feelings because I'm like oh
[__] I don't want to be like I don't
want to be known as a jerk I I'm a
pretty kind guy I thought so I hate
hearing that but it is the truth
[Laughter]
yeah I think Sam's intimidating to work
with uh you know I think that I've seen
a bunch of people around the podcast
that are intimidating but it's a good
thing it's a standard like the people
who have really high standards for how
they want things to go they're
intimidating to work with like for me we
come on here something's messed up the
camera the audio whatever I'm hey don't
worry it's gonna be a great show I'm
trying to put that person at ease and
I'm like they probably feel like [__] I
know they didn't want this to happen uh
you know like and a lot of these things
are I know like that's not you
intentionally messing something up
that's like something is going wrong
somebody's late so something out of your
control is happening or as Sam gets
frustrated I could see that person start
to sweat and I don't think that's rude I
just think that's like I think you're
focused and I think you uh you know
you're just like you're like a blunt
object it's like what are you gonna say
say like this Hammer is not very soft no
it's a [__] Hammer we that we that's
why we like it that's why it has that's
why it gets the best spot on the tool
side because it's this like really like
heavy blunt object and that's what you
need and like for the podcast the
podcast would not be successful without
Sam like that's just he brings that to
the Pod and so I love that now with that
comes well I you know sometimes it's not
gonna be you know not everyone's gonna
get treated with soft gloves and that's
okay like you know if you know the guy's
intent is good then you you don't really
worry about it so I don't know that's
that's my uh I don't know my feedback
that's good yeah no that that's on brand
and then Sean let me I I know I'm here
for you guys to ask me questions but I
want to ask you a question uh which is
you know like you obviously are a great
Storyteller you're very good on camera
how much of that do you think is is
natural like you're just born with it
let me ask it keep going keep going keep
going let me let me answer it first part
about the camera enter I was gonna say
how much do you think you're born with
and how much are you have you studied
like are you and what are you doing to
get better at it because I've listened
to the podcast for three years and you
just increasingly upped your game and
gotten better and I mean it's pretty
it's pretty incredible so let me give my
perspective and then he should answer
but so from the time I knew Sean he was
always pretty good he would we would we
would do these like the the podcast
stemmed because me him and sieve and a
few other guys would meet weekly or
monthly and like do kind of what we're
doing now and Sean was always good at at
like I I would explain something and be
like well so what you're really saying
is this so here's how you should look at
it and he would like storytell in such a
way where I'm like oh wow you've got
this like inspirational like thing about
you that's really good and then so he
always had that I think that was like a
I think he was born with that and then
we started the Pod and he was a little
rough where I actually think early on I
was better than him at like capturing
attention and then he started learning
about copywriting I think I was like you
should learn about this copy or anything
and then he got really good at
copywriting and then he got really good
at storytelling like on a more refined
basis and basically what happened was
because he was born with this I think
this innate ability as well as he wanted
to learn about it and then he actually
studied it his trajectory and his growth
was quicker than mine and I think he
actually surpassed it in terms of like
storytelling and ability to capture
attention and if you won't listen to
like the first couple of episodes you
could clearly see like because of his
tone of voice and everything like all
right this person's intriguing but then
it was like he studied it over a year
and you could see that there was a huge
change and I think it was in part of him
studying copywriting and I do think he
like actually went and studied like
Hassan uh Hassan and like all these
other comedians he like figured out we
both like comedians but I think he
studies it and we'll like tweet it or
message each other like hey let's look
at how they like told this joke it was
really interesting and so he actually
studied that and truly learned it and so
I think it was a combination of being
born and studying over like two years is
that is that accurate
uh I think some things you said they
were accurate sure
um my and nobody knows right like it's a
possible question to answer but like
I'll give it my best shot here's my
honest opinion my honest opinion is I I
don't actually think I'm that good at it
in at Absolute terms I just think it's
relative to Tech business and like
podcasts when I've seen you with like
professionals and they like Comedians
and I saw that they were like coming to
you for advice I've seen it
yeah okay that happens but I think the
I don't know I grew up in Houston and
Houston's just got like a very high swag
factor and like they're like I play
basketball in the locker room there were
dudes that like should have been on
stage at the Apollo or something like
that like just the natural Charisma of
people who were just uh and you know
that I grew up with were was just really
really high so I think that actually has
a lot to do with it would you hang out
with people who naturally have a lot of
Swag and Charisma and tell funny jokes
or stories are able to to just quickly
jump in and have quick wit
that just becomes your normal so I think
part of it was that some environment
stuff my sister for example is way
funnier way better Storyteller than me
and growing up it was always
Sean's the smart nice one but he's quiet
he's shy she's the funny one charismatic
if something happened to me they'd be
like Nisha tell the story about like
Sean like let Nisha tell the story
everyone will love it so at every family
party it was her doing and you know so
imagine that like the person you admire
your your older sibling is really great
at this thing and you just constantly
see your family and friends are like
everybody loves that about them so to me
it became like an important thing in my
life I was like not in a negative way
not like a jealousy but I was like it
was a thing I valued I was like oh
that's a really cool skill I value that
I had no idea how to do it and when I
was younger I was just super super quiet
so I didn't talk that much in my friends
group I was just the I was the laugh
track I wasn't the guy making the jokes
I was the crowd noise and
um but I started to I got a couple lucky
breaks my cousin was in town and was
like Hey you know there's a movie
audition going on like you want to come
with me and I just like I guess so I
don't know and so I went with him and I
ended up getting cast in the movie
um and that like showed me that exposed
me to a different thing and the the guy
in the movie who was my brother was uh
Cal Penn who was the guy from Harold and
Kumar and stuff like that so I got to
hang out with him for like weeks at a
time so now I'm around somebody else
who's very charismatic very good
Storyteller but he's like a professional
actor right so he was somebody I admired
that I was hanging out with for weeks
he's the only guy I talked to on set
because I was intimidated by everybody
else and he was super nice to me and so
we just hung out every day for like you
know six weeks so that's like kind of a
boot camp in like just being around
somebody who's got that Charisma okay
then fast forward uh I moved to San
Francisco
and I'm like okay
um I want to be like you know
I don't know in my mind I was like a CEO
should be the leader the leader should
be inspiring charismatic clear
I'm none of those things so how am I
gonna do all that and so I like tried to
do things I took you know I went to the
SF improv I took classes there all the
time right because I was like I don't
know it's fun I might meet some people
but also I think this I think improv is
just like a crazy skill set to have like
to be able to on your feet be able to
think of something and you know make a
crowd laugh that that to me is a actual
superpower and it's a superpower I
wanted to have same thing with comedians
like I like that content but I don't
just watch it and let's just let drool
come out of my mouth that oh wow these
people are funny I'm like I want to be
funny I love how funny they are and like
what do they do when they tell stories
um to you know that makes it work and
I'll go re-watch it and I'll sort of
break it down sometimes I'll I'll try it
myself uh like for example when I did
that Luna video I did it in the style of
like there's John Oliver or hustle Minaj
like skits and mine is like you know 10
times worse and I texted it to husband
he was like cool change these 95 things
and I was like ah dude that's a lot to
change I'm just gonna ship it like you
know I I don't have time to do all that
but like now that you've told me this I
now know what I should have done but
it's just those reps like it's Talent
helps but then there's reps and people
don't really see the Reps and I would
say like that combination of the three
things I mentioned like being around
people who are who are better at it than
you and you admire them that plants a
little seed inside you right like also
you were talking about that with money
like when you've met people with more
money it was inspiring and you're like
oh wow my World opened up I now have
like people I can sort of like you know
I could try to embody a blueprint that
that maybe they have uh to something I
want that's how it was with storytelling
and sort of like I don't know Charisma
or something like that for me and so
that you know being around people who
admire uh putting yourself in unusual
situations that are like kind of
intensives like improv or acting in
movies stuff like that most people in
business don't have that experience so
they shouldn't be as good at it right
like if you've never gone through these
intense experiences and then you know
how would you have developed those
skills why are you asking that Austin
are you trying to like get better at
talking or what
yeah I want to get better at public
speaking so 2023 goal I guess I'm going
to uh New York Improv
dude I I you're gonna probably I think
some people are born better but I think
everyone can get at least good but I do
think Sean has this like something that
will make him great and uh it is it's
very uh well let me just put it this way
Austin have you ever watched back a
video of you speaking publicly in order
to take notes on yourself of how you did
yeah
super uncomfortable feeling but an
obvious thing to do if you wanted to get
better yeah right like I just had that
moment where I was like oh I'm saying I
want to get better at this I've never
done any of the obvious things you would
do right I've never like went and
watched myself and said what the hell am
I doing with my hands and why am I
fidgeting so much am I oh man I keep
saying um at the start of these
sentences I should just say the sentence
but like I had to go review the game
film okay then the second thing was like
I had to take it seriously like did I
just walk up there unprepared and not
warm or do I warm up or do I prepare
okay that that added to the game and
then the third one is like who's the
best at this and I went to a Tony
Robbins event I was like this guy's like
the best public speaker I've ever seen
and even if I don't listen to any of his
content if I just literally listen to
the rhythm of his words and the gestures
and then the the hooks and how he's
getting everyone's attention
that's a master class right there like
okay I'll take that and so that's how I
started stacking up some of these things
and I don't consider myself a good
public speaker because I don't do a lot
of speeches or anything like that
anymore but
um it's definitely something at a time I
try to build up and it accommodated in
an epic wedding speech I gotta say the
best speech I ever gave was at my
wedding unrehearsed off the Dome and
just like it was I don't know the
perfect the perfect speech I just
retired from the game right there at
your own wedding
at my own way yeah is there a is there
anything else you want to talk about
Austin it's pretty cool you should come
on More by the way we should talk about
newsletter [__] because you're like the
only person or us three or some of the
very few people that like I actually
want to ask newsletter advice from
um and like yeah I'm trying to get out
of the the newsletter guy branding but
just keep on bringing me on to be the
newsletter guy dude but it's not it is
so fun it's a love-hate relationship
it's really they're really fun to do but
also they're painful and
whatever
yeah
no I think that's it I think we we cover
most of it
what do you think you're gonna be doing
like 10 years from now you're gonna you
think you'd be running businesses you're
gonna be just investing or a big
business or something what he wants or
what so to me it's it's barbell right I
either wanna you know have some passive
income and you know work 20 25 hours a
week more casual or I want to go all in
but if I go all in it's got to be huge
right the potential has to be multiple
billions I don't think I'm going to want
to run a business where it's like it's
nice and it's like a double right if I
win it's a double I don't want doubles
right I either want a home run or I want
to you know sit in the Dugout and just
you know be be part of the the peanut
gallery I don't want to play in that
middle game I'm going to look in the
future and I'm gonna tell you it's
probably not going to be you sitting in
the Dugout that is not going to be this
is I think maybe you will for a couple
years but if I have to make a bet and I
would put my money where my mouth is
it's not going to be that one that's not
what you're gonna do we'll see well
thanks for coming on dude this is
awesome yeah thanks for having me let's
do it again soon
[Music]